[Music]
you are not qualified you're a
bodybuilder you the bodybuilding we
should talk about that stuff speaking
against a legitimate rulership so are
you not do you not have the trait I mean
it's like a mirror you know the irony is
quite funny you are calling themar but
by doing that you become a Kar
don't we all hate it when we have done
woodo and the floor is absolutely
flooded and then we have to worry about
wiping it doing mopping waiting it to
dry opening the windows well we have a
solution our brother and sisters wood
mat.com go there and choose from a
brilliant range of free colors that
absorbs water instantly with their
amazing technology so brothers and
sisters inshallah go and audios now and
what's more beautiful and amazing about
this company it is Muslim own and 10% of
their profits go to supporting our
brothers and sisters in Gaza so brothers
and sisters do not miss this opportunity
now and stop getting that floor wet and
flooded get
[Music]
now alikum guys so basically we have uh
our great Imam the big she of our time
Faris hammadi at it again so he is
reacting to the rebels um who obviously
the Western Government has identified as
a terrorist group but they are actually
having discussion about taking them off
the terrorist group list now depends so
we our judgment is not really based on
what the Western world thinks about here
the Assad regime has been taken over a
CF kufar regime who saw Assad as Allah
or their belief is that Ali has
attributes for Allah subh T so here is
Farris again showing his support to
Muslims saving the lives if not of
hundreds of thousand people what Assad
done in
Syria is can for some can be as worse or
even worser than what is going on in
Gaza he killed
600,000 they're saying even more of
Sunni Muslims okay I'm not going to get
into the politics of it but here is the
video and here is what Farris had to say
his support as we know for Gaz has been
immense for the boycott oh my gosh it's
been speechless he's supported the
boycott mov so much go to McDonald's and
buy McDonald's okay we can clearly see
where his Allegiance is and for what
reasons here is the video of the rebels
again I am not pro or against against
I'm just stating call me a journalist
whatever you want to in here is the clip
of some soldiers under the Rebels the
the the HTS group and they had to say
some things and here is Farris showing
his support on Twitter let's watch for
ourself in
[Music]
ISL
all
[Music]
for for
you saw that for yourself now as a
Muslim obviously there are certain
things which I can deem problematic for
example I don't know what they meant by
we're going to take the mosque of
Muhammad s Al wasallam um and we can
even say you know the fact that he
didn't say peace be upon Him Oram we can
give the benefit of Doubt no problem and
talking about Mecca what does this mean
what do they mean by this it can sound
problematic are they trying to say that
they want to overthrow those governments
there's a whole discussion on that I'm
not going to go to the nitty but what's
very bizarre is the fact here Farris is
somebody who obeys the rulers yes and I
follow the sunah which is that we should
not rebel against the rulers 100% but he
is someone that at any condition if they
whatever they did to his if they were to
come and do you know kidnap his wife or
his daughters Etc like it seems like at
any cost he will support the rebels
however for some odd reason we can say
by Islamic rulings if we look at it that
this group has taken over a caic
government and now they are the Muslim
rulers we should not be speaking out
against rulers shouldn't we FIS is that
what you not tell us that whatever
happens whatever they do whatever is for
that matter even they have ties with
Israel but they're committing atrocities
in Israel against Palestinian brothers
and sisters uh there should be diplomacy
the ruler should decide that blah blah
blah the ruler the ruler the ruler you
talk about the ruler so much and the
rights that they have Etc and it's from
the Sunnah of course certain things that
you say but you um blur the lines why
are you not respecting the new ruler of
Syria now I'm just asking a question why
are you not saying he's the ruler he's
the Amir whatever he says I like it I
don't like it but all of a sudden you
are replying by saying what you are
calling them number one you're not
qualified you're a bodybuilder you
started as a bodybuilder I don't know
how you became a she overnight you're a
bodybuilder yes you never supported Gaza
you mocked the boycott movement yes you
telling people to go on still eatting
McDonald's Your Allegiance is very clear
where it is and it's been made very
clear many times you've been exposed but
I'm asking you a simple question this is
hypocrisy at his finest you talk about
the Amir submitting to the Amir why are
you because right now you calling them
actually shows you to beish based on
your standards because you are now
rebelling vocally if you remember you
was talking at one point that even if
you vocally you know speak against the
ruler you are what or have the trait of
well right now you are speaking against
a legitimate rulership so are you not do
you not have the trait I mean it's like
a mirror you know the irony is quite
funny you are calling them Kar but by
doing that you become a Kar in your
standards by the way I'm not saying
anybody because I know my place what I
can say not not I should not say you are
not qualified to you are not qualified
you're a bodybuilder you're the
bodybuilding we should talk about that
stuff yes okay you have never supported
the Gaza cause Palestinian cause you are
always talking about oh yeah we should
support the rulers whatever for that
matter and now because of what they said
now was it problematic what they said
about taking over the prophet Mam's
Masjid of Mecca yes that was problematic
that seemed not only that but nobody can
come out and then say because they said
this therefore they number one number
two These Are Soldiers this is not the
Amir this is not jalani yes this is not
him coming out and saying this he's not
saying that these can be a few soldiers
in if an Amir would you if there was the
ruler of um wherever it is for that
matter that you bow down to at any cost
Etc if some of the soldiers made a
statement without the authority of the
ruler you will make 1 million excuses
that came from the soldiers they didn't
mean it like that you make thousand
excuses why you not making one for them
why you not making one for them and say
you know what hold on a second the
soldier said this but this is not Jani
this is not the head figure you want
would you you want would you because the
people above you Your Puppet Masters
they are the ones who are calling the
shots and they are using the Sunnah to
justify what they are doing and again I
said it very clearly ruling against
rebelling against a ruler it's not good
and we've seen atrocities however Assad
regime the kuf they are kuf okay Assad
and they are kufar literally it's clear
the matter is clear even the sh of them
yeah so the matter is very clear but I
just want to show people your double
standards and hypocrisy that's what you
are and you are calling them the dogs of
the Hellfire anyone that comments
attacking FIS he puts a fire picture and
a dog picture meaning he sees them as
the dogs of the hell he probably deems
them to be disbelievers cfers if he
follows that opinion that's all I wanted
to say guys and just say you know what
these kind of people may Allah subh
guide them I'm not going to speak ill of
him or call him names or whatever for
that matter cuz I don't want to give my
good deals to anyone like him he's an
opportunistic individual who looks for
the downfall of others he did the same
with myself long time ago when I had a
debate one debate debate Etc and
obviously I did some things I was not
proud of Etc that was not Haram he jumps
at opportunity looking for the mistakes
of anyone who doesn't like and when it
comes to the rulers and things that
benefit him at all cost said this Etc
yeah and he decides who's so for you to
it backfires on you because this is an
action words against a legitimate ruler
so submit to him bro submit to him till
next
time from London to Dubai FIS look after
yourself take care carry on body the
building